[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully
it is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor john ross
hello friends welcome to bible answers
live pastor doug is out this evening but
how about an amazing fact
in 1913 the little country of albania in
eastern europe achieved its independence
there were many muslims in albania and
they chose as their leader a turkish
prince named haleem adeem
prince hadeem seemed reluctant at first
to leave his native turkey but one day a
telegraph was received saying that he
would shortly arrive in the albanian
city of dorazo
the people of dirazo turned out in force
to greet the prince
they could tell at once that he was a
nobleman he spoke with authority wore a
splendid uniform and carried a long
sword
when he told them that he would lead an
attack against the heated city of
belgrade they went wild with joy
the people of the city quickly declared
the prince to be the king of albania
the new king chose a strange name for a
muslim
otto the first
but the people were not critical of
their hero
they cheered him everywhere and showered
him with costly gifts
everyone was happy
five days later however another
telegraph arrived
otto the first it said was a fraud
the real prince adeem was still in
turkey
but the people rushed to king otto to
find out the truth
but the king was gone
for otto the first was really
otterweight a german circus performer
who had carried out one of the boldest
hoaxes in history
friends did you know that the bible
predicts that one of the greatest
impersonations of all
is soon to come
actually it was jesus that warned his
followers in matthew 24 24 he said for
false christs and false prophets will
rise and show great signs and wonders to
deceive if possible even the very elect
so the bible warns us that before jesus
comes there is going to be a lot of
deception in the world good evening
pastor carlos welcome hello pastor
gianna it's good to have you here good
to be back now we're talking about one
of these great deceptions that the devil
is going to do before the end of uh
before christ comes and well the bible
tells us that he's even going to try and
impersonate jesus
you know there's an interesting verse in
revelation chapter 16 verse 14 that says
speaking of end time events for they are
the spirits of demons performing signs
or miracles so just because somebody
performs a miracle that doesn't mean
that they of god
how are we to know whether someone is
genuine or if they're a counterfeit well
the bible tells us in isaiah chapter 20
isaiah chapter 8 verse 20 it says to the
law and to the testimony if they do not
speak according to this word it is
because there is no light in them so
what is to be our guide pastor carlos
when it comes to determining what is
genuine
or what is counterfeit
well god gave us his word so that we can
distinguish between what is what is his
and what is not so we have to go by the
bible and what the bible says amen not
by our feelings or our emotions but what
does god say in his word
do you think even in the world today
there are these false spirits or evil
spirits performing miracles under the
name of christianity and maybe even in
churches today oh yeah i mean i remember
in second corinthians chapter 11 paul
speaks about
these false teachers and they masquerade
as satan who also presents himself as an
angel of light and he has his ministers
that are also sharing and scattering
deceit and lies and and misinterpreting
scripture too so so at the end it's very
important to know what the bible says on
this important subject well we do have a
study guide it's actually one of our
books that we have it's dealing with the
second coming of christ and it's very
important it's called anything but
secret and this is our free offer to
anyone listening if you'd like to
receive it all you need to do is call
the number 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book by name
it's called anything but secret or offer
number 106 and we'll be happy to send it
to anyone in north america that's
800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book anything
but secret and we'll be happy to send it
to you if you're outside of north
america they can still receive the book
pastor carlos but just go to the amazing
facts website
amazingfacts.org click on the tab that
says free library and you can read it
you can read a digital copy right there
online so that's something you can do
right away you know we also want to
greet some of our new radio stations
folks who are listening in different
areas
we went live
in tampa bay florida and i think tonight
might be our first or our second live
broadcast there so we want to greet our
friends listening in tampa bay if you're
in the area and you have a bible
question give us a call the number to
call is
800-463-7297 that is our phone line here
to the studio and also we have another
radio station live going live i think
today as well
in dallas texas so we want to greet our
friends listening in dallas texas uh if
you're listening in that area and have a
bible question we love to hear from you
the number again is 800-4636
this is bible answers live it's a live
interactive international bible study
and if you have a question about the
bible about living the christian life
our phone lines are open we'll be happy
to search the scriptures together to
find bible answers
pastor carlos before we actually go to
the phone lines and begin our bible
study it's always good to start with the
word of prayer amen because the bible is
god's book and we need the holy spirit
to guide us so why don't you stop with
prayer let's pray father thank you for
another day of life and thank you for
the privilege of having your word and as
we now open it because we want to help
each other find answers to understanding
your will and the things that are
happening in this world we ask that your
spirit guide us and direct us so that
everything that is said and done may be
in harmony with with your word so we
thank you again for this privilege and
we ask this in jesus name amen amen
well our phone lines are open friends
again that number is 800 835 no way
actually that's our free offer now
the call number is 800-463-7297
we also want to greet those who are
watching live on af tv also live
streaming on youtube
and on facebook and again if you want to
call in we'd love to hear from you this
evening
who's our first caller tonight
first caller we have glenn from ohio
good evening glenn welcome to bible
answers live
good evening thank you for taking my
call
as you know the bible says that there's
no other name under heaven by where you
must be saved
but i don't believe that it tells what
name that is is it jehovah or jesus or
is in the word name antecedent back to
something that gives that away okay well
good question i think the answer to that
is just simply the name referred to
there is the name of the messiah which
is jesus now of course there's different
ways to pronounce the word jesus in
english it's jesus
uh hebrew would be more yahshua so there
are different ways of pronouncing the
name but the name refers to the person
and the person is christ our only hope
of salvation is in
jesus also in the bible names have
significance and names referred to the
person they represent the person
uh when it came to the birth of jesus an
angel gave joseph the message that his
his name should be jesus and then it
tells us he shall save his people from
their sins so christ is the savior he's
the one to save us
is it important pastor carlos that we
pronounce the name of jesus a certain
way or is there a certain language do we
have to pronounce his name in hebrew or
aramaic in order for us to be saved or
what does it mean there's no other name
no i just think that
this like ours your name is jean right
and in spanish it would be one right so
we change the names depending on on the
differences for example
in the in greek in the new testament was
written in greek when paul writes
when paul is writing about jesus he uses
the greek word jesus right because
that's their language at that time even
though we know that the name comes in
hebrew jesus so some people do get
caught up with that but at the end of
the day is who are you talking about who
are you thinking about who are you
contemplating if you say messiah if you
say christ if you're the jesus if you
say jesus
if you say
it's it's the person right that's right
the name represents the person so anyone
everyone that will be saved will be
saved because of the sacrifice of christ
they are saved by faith in jesus in the
messiah and that's the important point
you know we do have a book it's called
the name of god and it's a free gift
we'll send it to anyone who calls and
asks if you'd like to receive the book
all you need to do is call our resource
phone number that's 800-835-6747
and ask for the book that's called the
name of god and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and asks amen all
right who do we have next next we have
from switzerland we have katja calling
us hello katya
hello good evening pastors it's very
nice to to take my call
i have a question about the old
testament which might seem a little bit
mundane
is there any mentioning of sweets or
like dessert in the old testament
sweets or desserts well you know the
idea of something being sweet is found
in the bible you also find it with
reference to salvation you find it in
reference to the word of god and
sometimes the word honey is used
speaking of the land of promise it was
referred to as the land flowing with
milk and honey
and psalms 119 speaks of the word of god
as sweet as honey more precious than
silver and gold so the idea of honey
would be sweet
not so much of a dessert per se but the
idea of something being sweet is found
and it symbolizes the word of god it
symbolizes the promised land uh hope for
the redeemed and that's that's what
refers to but back in those days i think
the sweetest thing you get was honey
grapes grapes are sweet and of course
dates you could get a type of date honey
as well which is also very sweet
but that's pretty much it they didn't
have cane sugar like of course we have
it today
yes the the point came up after concert
the musicians saying about
what the people what you all would do
when the messiah comes
and they had um
uh citations from the bible like sing
like salomon or dems like moses and eat
a banquet and then when i said oh you
forgot about the dessert they said
there's no mention of dessert um
in the old testament and i said okay i
will find that until the next concert
they
play music which is half um
traditional and often with religious um
religious themes so that's why why the
the question came up yeah you know i
think uh not specifically dessert but if
you look back and even today in the
middle east often a meal will end with
some fruit or something sweet
and fruit was considered much more of a
delicacy back in bible times than we
might consider today because of course
you didn't have certain fruits all year
round so when it was grape time and the
grapes were you know ready for harvest
that would be something special you
might eat that at the end of your meal
whether it was dates or whatever it
might be so fruit was used
almost like a dessert
and was available at the end of the meal
that's a good point though do we have a
verse
not specifically of them eating fruit at
the end of the meal that's just you know
more cultural but with reference to at
any time yes with reference to honey
there are a number of references
starting all the way back in genesis 43
11.
um it's also interesting to note just
something came to mind when jacob sent
sent gifts to joseph who was in egypt
and they didn't know that it was joseph
when he sent his sons to get grain
during the famine he gathered the best
of the land that he could and it
included dates
and so that was considered a delicacy
back in those times still now
genesis 43
genesis chapter 43 11 you also find
honey referred to in exodus 3 verse 8
speaking of the land of promise
and then there are many references to
honey throughout the old testament
yeah thank you thank you very much all
right you're welcome thanks for your
call
next we have angela from illinois good
evening angela
ah thank you um hi pastor ross and
pastor carlos i have a question in
regards to luke um chapter 16
verses 19 through 31 it talks about the
rich man and lazarus um i was reading it
and i don't really understand it um i
assume it's a parable so can you explain
it to me please yes great question you
find this in luke chapter 16 starting
verse 19 sometimes referred to as the
parable of the rich man and lazarus
actually the heading that i have in the
new king james version is just that it
says the parable of the rich man and
lazarus it's in the context of a number
of parables but what's unique about this
parable is that we have a character who
has a specific name it's very important
and that person's name is lazarus and
we're going to get to why in this
parable
there is somebody that has a specific
name uh for those who might be new to
the parable you can find in verse 19 it
talks about a certain rich man who was a
jew
and he lived very well but there was a
beggar and the vegas name was lazarus
and the beggar would be at his gate
begging for something to eat but the
rich man
sort of ignored the beggar
and in the story they both die
and the rich man goes to in verse 23 a
place of torment called hades and we can
say something about that in just a
minute but lazarus who was the poor man
the beggar he ends up in a place that's
referred to as abraham's bosom
and so lazarus is in a place of paradise
and the rich man is in a place of
torment
and then it says they are talking one to
another
and the rich man who is in hades says to
abraham he says it's hot down here i'm
paraphrasing please put a drop of water
on my tongue
and the message comes back from abraham
and says you know remember during your
lifetime you received all the good
things
whereas lazarus the beggar the poor man
he received the bad things now lazarus
is comforted and you are tormented and
then he goes on to talk about a great
gulf that is fixed
well then verse 27 then he said i beg of
you father this is the rich man in hades
talking to abraham i beg of your father
that you would send him that's lazarus
very important to my father's house
for i have five brothers that they may
testify to them lest they also come to
this place of torment
abraham said they have moses and the
prophets let them hear
them verse 30 and he said no father
abraham they will believe if someone
were to go from the dead verse 31 here's
the key point but he said to him
if they do not hear moses and the
prophets neither will they be persuaded
though one is raised from the dead so in
the parable you have this man by the
name of lazarus he's a beggar
and you have the rich man symbolizing
the nation of israel the religious
leaders of the day
and here the message is if lazarus were
raised from the dead they would believe
jesus says if they don't believe moses
and the prophets meaning the scriptures
they won't believe even if someone is
raised from the dead now what's amazing
about the story
just
a short time after talking about a
matter of weeks even days after jesus
told this parable there was somebody
raised from the dead whose name was
lazarus and still the religious leaders
refused to believe that jesus was the
christ so this is a prophecy that christ
is really making concerning the fact
that even though lazarus would rise from
the dead they would still stubbornly
refuse because they rejected the
testimony of moses this is not a
discourse to talk about what happens
when a person dies because the bible
tells us in many places that the dead
know not anything
that you're in the grave until the
resurrection at the second coming of
christ this is a parable like all of the
other parables to teach a very important
lesson
and that's the main thrust of what he's
been taught in this parable also the
imagery that jesus is using is using
greek mythology when he's talking about
abraham's bosom
when he's talking about a place of
torment that's common that was common to
the greeks that what that's what they
believe that when you died you went to
place torment or you went up to a place
of paradise and jesus is using something
that they were familiar with to
illustrate an important truth the truth
being you won't believe even if somebody
is raised from the dead and oh by the
way his name name's going to be lazarus
and they still didn't believe which to
me is amazing it's an incredible parable
it really is a powerful story in the
context
of what jesus was doing
oh wow this is great thank you i
understand it now oh great question
thanks for your call
amen thank you
don't we have a book also we have uh you
know i think we do um it might be called
the rich man in last year yeah i think
it is
and angela you might want to call and
ask for that we'll be happy to send it
to you just call 800-835-6747
and ask for the book called the rich man
and lazarus that'll go into a lot more
detail than we have time to talk about
right here on the air
good question who do we have next uh
next olivia from washington welcome to
bible answers live
hi thank you for taking my call
my question
well a few days ago i
was looking at my dad's bible and it
opened to a random place
and it just
it was somewhere in first corinthians
and
it said something about
if women did not have their head covered
when they prophesied
then
their head would be disgraced and i was
wondering what that meant
okay good good question i think the
verse you're referring to is first
corinthians chapter 11
and it starts around verse 4 5
and i think it goes all the way through
to about 8. and it's talking about in
the church
the context here paul is writing a
letter to the believers in the city of
corinth
this church was made up of both jews and
gentiles more so gentiles it seems and
there were a lot of people coming and
going and if you read the rest of not
only first corinthians but also second
corinthians
paul was helping the church to to get
organized there seemed to be some
confusion in the church
uh things weren't being done right and
so paul is writing a letter and he's
giving some practical guidance to the
church members as to how they were to
perform the services how what they were
to do in church and one of the things
that is mentioned here if you find in
verse 4 first corinthians 11 verse 4
it says every man praying or prophesying
that means preaching
having his head covered dishonors his
head but every woman who prays or
prophesies with her head uncovered
dishonors her head for that is one of
the same as if
her head was shaved now let me give you
the context as a sign of respect and
reverence back in those days in that
culture similar to as it is today
for a man to enter a church
it is respectful for him to remove his
hat that's true even if somebody goes to
somebody else's house but especially a
church if somebody enters the church the
respectful thing is to remove your hat
it is a cultural thing but that's true
just for men it's not true for a woman
matter of fact there are many women that
wear a head covering or a hat when they
go to church and it's actually a sign of
reverence and respect
and that's what paul is emphasizing he
says when you go to church you need to
show forth respect
and if that involves for a man removing
your hat then remove your hat or your
head covering for a woman if you're
going to be up front if you're going to
be leading in the prayer you want to
cover your head meaning you want to show
respect and reverence so the whole point
here he's talking about reverence and
respect and there was a traditional
component to that because
pastor carlos you know different
cultures around the world do things
differently i've spent some time in
india and it's true that when a woman
goes to the front of the church or even
if she enters the church it's very
common for her to cover her head
it's appropriate for a man to remove his
his hat if he goes in but also another
sign of reference is the removing of
their shoes
so when you're going to the church
you'll often see in the front of the
church there are all kinds of shoes or
sandals that's there now that's not the
way it is in north america in a western
style conch
culture but whenever i go to india and
i'm asked to preach i'll always remove
my shoes i'll be up there in my socks it
feels a little odd at first but that's a
sign of reverence and that's the point
that paul is emphasizing that when it
comes to worship and it comes to the
church things need to be done decent and
in order amen
yeah so hopefully that helps a little
bit olivia
thank you that did help
all right thanks nicole awesome
next we have daryl from florida welcome
to bible answers live
good evening pastors
so
my question is which of the plagues
mentioned in revelation 16 are literal
and which are symbolic and if we have
enough time when does satan show up
posing as christ before the plagues or
during the plagues okay well good
question let's take the first part of
the question um which of the plagues the
seven last plagues that we find in
revelation 16 are literal or symbolic i
think the first four plagues are literal
the first one is a painful saw that
comes upon those they're the mark of the
beast then it talks about the sea
turning to a substance that is like
blood
and then the springs in the rivers
turning to a blood-like substance
and then you find the fourth where it
talks about an intense heat and people
are scorched with heat
so those first four
first four plagues would would be
literal i mean these are things that are
judgments that are coming upon the earth
but then when you get to the next plague
you find darkness on the on the seat of
the beast power
there is a literal application of that
because i believe there will be a
darkness that will settle over the beast
power that you read about in revelation
but it's also symbolic in that it
reveals that this entity this religious
power that claims to be preaching or
teaching the truth is actually preaching
lies
and it's dark
and then the sixth plague is the drying
up of the river euphrates making way for
the kings of the east
that is symbolic we know in bible
prophecy water represents multitudes and
nations and kindreds and tongues and so
we find the support that these various
kingdoms and nations gave to symbolic
babylon
or the beast power will be withdrawn in
preparing the way for the second coming
the kings of the east here symbolize
jesus and the angels coming to bring
deliverance to god's people
so the sixth plague and then the seventh
plague it talks about an earthquake and
hail that's definitely got literal
applications as well that brings you
right up to the second coming of christ
so yes they both literal but they also
definitely have spiritual applications
does that help daryl
oh yeah and if we have time when does
satan show up posing as christ before
the plagues or during the plagues i
think there's a little bit of both i
think there is before probation closes
the plagues fall after probation closes
i think before probation closes there's
going to be false christs and false
prophets performing signs and wonders
but i also think during the plagues near
the end there's going to be a final
gathering together of all of the nations
because according to revelation chapter
13 it speaks about a death decree that
is eventually passed against those who
keep the commandments of god now their
death decree is never enforced because
jesus comes before that happens but i
think during the time period of the
plagues and even before there will be a
special or an increase of these false
christs
and false prophets and even the devil
himself claiming to be christ
and deceiving the whole world
and united and that's what i'm in the
opposition referring to is
that's what i'm referring to is when
satan himself uh
poses as christ you think it's going to
be like at the sixth plague when it
talks about uh
the frogs coming out of the dragon's
mouth and out of the beast and out of
the false prize yes the three unclean
spirits out of the mouth the dragon the
beast the false prophet yes that's an
application to that as well
don't think of of the impersonation of
christ by the devil as being
an experience that occurs just quickly
the devil is going to be here for a
while and he's going to be involved in
deceiving people over an extended period
of time
he's going to be galvanizing the world
so it could even begin a little bit
before but definitely culminates during
the three unclean spirits that you read
about in revelation 16.
all right thanks for your call darryl
good good question appreciate it
all right who do we have next lucas from
tennessee welcome to bible answers live
hey pastors um so my question is uh
where do dinosaurs fit in the biblical
timeline um my current understanding is
they
are probably
pre-flood and possibly the results of
amalgamation which could explain why
they weren't on the arc okay yeah good
question uh as far as the the dinosaurs
yes they did exist before the flood and
the reason we have so many fossilized
remains of the dinosaurs is because of
the flood because of the various layers
of mud
destroyed the dinosaurs there were some
animals that you might consider close to
that category that actually made it on
the ark for example you have
the woolly mammoth which isn't a
dinosaur but it is extinct now we
believe it did make it on the ark
because they found some
pretty well pretty good preserved
remains of it but most of the dinosaurs
they were destroyed at the time of the
flood
others could not exist in the
environment that was created after the
flood there was a reduction of
vegetation there was changes in the
atmosphere and so these animals that
were so big they just couldn't exist
also we find all kinds of animals before
the flood that seemed to be a lot bigger
all the way from insects dragonflies and
others that were much bigger than what
we have now
so the whole environment was very
different uh before the flood then after
the flood well thank you for your your
call lucas friends we're going to be
taking a short break uh we'll be back
with more bible questions if you have a
bible question it's a good time to pick
up your phone and give us a call we'll
be right back
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
did you know that noah was present at
the birth of abraham
ok maybe he wasn't in the room but he
was alive and probably telling stories
about his floating zoo
from the creation of the world to the
last day events of revelation
biblehistory.com is a free resource
where you can explore major bible events
and characters enhance your knowledge of
the bible and draw closer to god's word
go deeper
visit biblehistory.com
hi friends pastor doug batchelor we are
very excited to be celebrating the
50-year anniversary of the amazing facts
bible school for 50 years now we've seen
tens of thousands of people go through
this study course and their lives have
been absolutely transformed so i'm here
with tammy steenson who is the amazing
facts bible school supervisor tammy what
are some of the different courses that
are offered in the series in the
correspondence course we offer two main
studies at children's and and adults and
it's both in spanish and english and on
the online course we have
two adult studies and we have a
children's study and they're in a
variety of different languages now does
a person need to be very familiar with
the bible to go through the course or
can anybody do it no anybody can do it
it's very basic starts out very basic
and gets more advanced as you go through
how do we see the lessons transforming
people's lives our graduating students
have shared with us that it's helped
them to grow spiritually in their
relationship with jesus christ and it
has also empowered them to witness in
their communities in their workplace and
within their family members so tammy if
a person person's now curious and they
want to go through the bible study
course how do they do that all they have
to do is go to
amazingbiblestudies.com and enroll
praise god and thank you friends for
supplying the resources to make this
bible school available for free for 50
years
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
hello friends welcome back this is bible
answers live a live interactive
international bible study we want to
welcome those who are joining us online
also listening on the various radio
stations
if you have a bible related question
we'd love to hear from you this evening
the number to call is
800-463-7297 that is a phone line here
to the studio and the lines are open
it's a good time to give us a call if
you don't get through right away i'll
just have a little patience stay on the
line and somebody will get to your call
as soon as possible pastor doug is out
this evening but we are taking your
questions and we have pastor carlos who
is helping with the phone lines and for
those of you who might not know who
pastor carlos is pastor carlos what do
you do here at amazing facts i am the
director for afco amazing facts center
of evangelism and i'm an associate
bilingual speaker okay history pastor
carlos is the spanish voice of a lot of
what we do here at amazing facts and we
have a website for those of you who
might be listening uh who understand
spanish or would like to see what
resources we have available what's the
website the spanish amazing facts
website amazing facts
okay latino.org and i believe we have
video content there as well as a lot of
written content and also some great
bible study resources amen and it's all
in spanish so you might want to take a
look at that okay well let's go to our
next caller who do we have next next we
have kenneth calling from michigan
welcome kenneth
praise the lord pastors
amen
and
good evening my question is over in the
book of
james where it says are there any sick
among you let them call for the elders
and let them anoint them and pray the
prayer of faith my question is what is
the prayer because it says the prayer of
faith i believe that that is a specific
prayer i don't believe it's the lord's
prayer i would like some enlightenment
on that okay great question you know the
bible tells us that we need to believe
that god is and that he is a rewarder of
those who diligently seek him
so the bible tells us that if somebody
is sick they are to call for the elders
of the church the leaders of the church
they are to gather around now to pray as
you mentioned the prayer of faith and
we'll talk about that anointing with oil
in the name of the lord and trust that
the person will be raised up now i've
been involved in the service i know
pastor carlos ii
and i have seen some wonderful answers
to prayer
where healing has occurred on multiple
occasions
but the ultimate promise that we find in
this verse is even if we are healed now
the greatest reward is the new body when
we are raised up at the second coming of
christ so there is a temporal healing
that we might experience now but the
promise is our sins will be forgiven if
we trust in the lord and will be raised
up when he comes well what is this
prayer of faith well i believe the
prayer of faith can be best summarized
by the words of jesus when jesus prayed
thy will be done
you know we come to the lord we give him
our request we say lord please heal us
or heal this person
we confess our sins
i want to make sure that we are right
with god and we pray in faith trusting
that the lord hears our prayer but
ultimately we also are willing to submit
to whatever god's will is for us
sometimes that can be a challenge
maybe the healing doesn't come as
quickly as we would like or maybe there
is a witness that we can be through this
ailment
you know pastor carlos i'm remember
reminded of the story of paul where he
had some kind of
ailment
and he prayed and he speaks about it
being a thorn in his side and he prayed
saying lord deliver me from this heal me
from this and the message came back my
grace is sufficient
for my strength is made perfect in
weakness
and so in that case paul was not healed
while he had faith he had the prayer of
faith he submitted to whatever the will
of god is so i think that's an important
component that we need to bear in mind
when we pray the prayer of faith we are
saying not my will thy will be done
does does that help kenneth
yes it does thank you so very much all
right we appreciate your call thanks for
calling you know we do have a book that
talks about prayer and it's called teach
us to pray and it's free we'll be happy
to send that to anyone who calls and
asks the number for that is 800-835-6747
and again the book is called teach us to
pray written by pastor doug we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks amen is our next caller next we
have shelley calling us from michigan
welcome shelly
good evening pastors thank you for
taking my call
i was just wondering if there's anything
in the bible that would um help me with
um my ex-husband and i are divorced and
have been for almost 10 years
and um
we're starting to get back together and
i'm just wondering if there's anything
in the bible that says that i can
remarry him or
further that relationship or am i not
supposed to do that
okay yeah good question so um if two
people are married and for some reason
the marriage falls apart but
uh they're still able to
be friends and the relationship is able
to grow and maybe both of them
experience a conversion
and they realize that they really do
love this person and they want to
recommit their lives and get remarried
that's perfectly appropriate now of
course if somebody is remarried in the
interim well no you can't get remarried
but if both individuals have remained
unmarried and they've been able to
come together and harmonize and
love each other and they want to
recommit to that marriage that's
perfectly appropriate according to the
bible
thank you so much i really do appreciate
that thank you all right you're welcome
thank you
thank you man
next we have lori from calling us from
indiana welcome to bible answers live
thank you for taking my call
yes and your question tonight laurie
well it's kind of hard to to voice it
my daughter recently had a drug overdose
and she became brain dead i want to know
where in the bible i could find if she
is still going to be able to go to
heaven she was saved and baptized but
obviously she was backslid and she i
don't think she had time to ask for
forgiveness
but she sent me prayer hands right
before because she'd ask me to come and
get her okay that she didn't want to be
yeah absolutely you know we don't know
the heart and i think that's why the
bible is very clear that it says it's
not for us to judge god knows the heart
it's also encouraging to know that god
doesn't judge us eternally based upon
maybe
one good decision we might make or one
bad decision but rather it's it's the
chain of our lives it's the direction of
our life and i think that's why it's
important for us not to judge god knows
and there are circumstances that might
occur you know i know of experiences
where somebody might have
been in incredible pain and in a moment
of weakness they
tried to commit suicide and they took
some some pills only to realize what
they had done
and they called and said i've made a
terrible mistake but it was too late
they confessed what they had done and
said lord please forgive me so we don't
know the heart probably the best thing
we could do is to recognize that god
loves our children even more than we do
and he will do everything he can to save
amen so we can pray and we can place
them in the hands of jesus
and trust that he knows what's best
and
thank god for his mercy and his grace
and just trusting him
you know he's just really been tearing
me up because i'm so afraid for her
because she's in a nursing home now
she's only 36 years old she can't speak
she can open her eyes and that's it she
can't talk or anything or move and uh
like i said i'd been trying to preach to
her and i told her she'd go to heaven
but i i didn't realize i mean if you
don't repent is there anywhere in the
bible that i could look that would tell
me this like
when she dies because she did die was
did her spirit leave or come back or
what no you know the good news is that
the bible says if there's life there is
hope so if someone is alive and they're
able to um understand
there is hope and again you don't know
how much she does understand um we don't
know what's happening in her mind we
don't know how the spirit is working so
we can pray for her
i've heard many stories again of people
who were
in a coma and people thought they
couldn't hear but actually they could
and you could still talk to them talk
about jesus uh you can ask her if she
will respond you can say have you
accepted jesus and give her an
opportunity
but you can keep encouraging her and you
don't know the lord might open up a
window or understanding might clear up
if she haven't if she's not made that
decision so just keep being the best
example that you can
and
place you in god's hands and trust in
him
thank you so much like if you would mind
praying for her also her name's angela
yeah we will definitely keep angeline
pray you know what lori let's pray right
now okay thank you dear father in heaven
we just want to come before you and we
want to lift up angelina a very special
way you know how dear our children are
to us and we know father they are dear
to you because you are our father so we
just pray for angela we pray for lori
and we ask that you would just keep your
hand over that situation lord and do
everything you can to save and we thank
you in jesus name amen amen amen praise
god god bless you thank you so much
bye-bye
anthony from new york you are live on
bible answers live welcome
yes good evening pastors can you hear me
okay yeah we can
okay good i think there's a delay on my
phone
we can hear you
question
is um
okay good
um my question is uh matthew based on
matthew chapter 10
um verse
verse two where it lists the disciples
um
two verses two through four actually
and so my question is we always hear
about the usual suspects peter andrew
james john
uh
judas thomas but then as i look in this
list i see there's a few that we never
at least i've never really heard much
about like bartholomew
um
uh
thaddeus
um and and ones like that or james son
of alphaeus and things like i know
there's one of them that was a suspect
to be the brother of jesus or something
like that or maybe that was the one that
wrote the book of james what i was
wondering if could you expound on
um maybe just giving us a little
background if there is any on some of
the other disciples and who they were
okay good question yes of course we're
very familiar with the disciples that
played a leading role
uh during the time of christ ministry we
know that peter james and john they
formed sort of an inner circle of
disciples that got to share some very
special experiences with jesus but the
other disciples were very devote they
were very committed they had some
wonderful experiences with jesus and
they were very involved after the
resurrection
in the early church other than of course
judas iscariot so they all had different
roles um the bible doesn't explain all
of what they did all of what all the
other disciples did uh there is some
traditions and i think
they're actually pretty solid
thomas one of the disciples is believed
to have gone to india as a missionary
after the resurrection
and he was killed in india and there's
actually an area in india that you can
go visit
where they believe
thomas was buried so all of the
disciples are involved in some type of
missionary activity the bible doesn't
give us a whole lot more about them in
the book of acts you have some of the
key people as you mentioned but the
focus of the book of acts is really the
gospel going out to the gentile world
and that's where paul plays such a
significant role in taking the gospel to
the world but the other disciples were
involved in the work in jerusalem up
until the destruction of jerusalem in 70
a.d and probably just prior to that
there was persecution that caused a lot
of the christians to scatter
but we don't have a whole lot of
reference other than that with reference
to what happened to the other disciples
we know they're all faithful other than
judas
judas iscariot
so hopefully that helps a little bit
anthony
yes thank you or do you have any
resources that talk about disciples at
all you know i'm trying to think if
amazing facts has anything i don't think
we have anything specific on that
we do reference there is a book called
the 144 000 it's talking about god's end
time sort of apostles that take the
three angels message or the gospel to
the world i'm not sure if it references
it might reference the 12 apostles in
that but it doesn't really give much of
the historical context
there there are historical books i know
fox's book of martyrs is one that comes
to mind that actually mentions the
number of the apostles that you don't
often hear about and how they died based
on tradition
and based on research that's been done
so you might want to take a look at that
i know i've read the first section of
that book that talks about what happened
to the apostles
all right thank you for your call
anthony who do we have next
eric from canada welcome to bible
answers live
hello
hi eric
uh yes i have a question
and your question tom
i've been um
really struggling you know with um
understanding like
you know um science and the bible
you know because um
because it just feels like there's just
so much evidence against the bible with
some science and you know
i know
all we could
we have um we struggle with like
understanding you know
origins like especially with creation
you know and the evolution um issue okay
so you know how do we overcome that
because it's been really um affecting my
faith on how i see the bible okay good
question um i'm going to have carlos
address this a little bit because your
experience is somewhat unique you know
if we look at signs correctly especially
through the lens of the bible
understanding the biblical account of
creation the flood what happened to the
dinosaurs
looking at it from a biblical
perspective makes a whole lot more sense
than going along with the idea of slow
change over long periods of time there
are just too many problems
with what often is referred to as the
popular understanding of evolution
where you have a lightning a bolt that
somehow affected some chemicals in a
pond on the earth and proteins were
formed and then suddenly the proteins
were able to create a cell and somehow
the cell knew that it had to divide
and
it had to separate its dna and it had to
have a nucleus and everything else in
place for a cell to have life the chance
of that happening by itself is
impossible
but understanding what the bible says
and then looking at science through the
lens of scripture everything fits in
together in a beautiful way and we can
understand creation we can understand
science far clearer if we look at it
from the bible perspective now pastor
carlos you weren't always a christian
and i believe it was science that really
led you to
uh search the scripture because things
weren't adding up yeah that's right it
was the study of science that's to make
me see the complexity and the how
everything is synchronized and
everything is orderly and has a purpose
and so what i would say eric is that
when you look at science remember
science is just the gathering of
information
uh through scientific experiments
through scientific instruments the
problems and thus is not the science but
the interpretation that many people give
of the scientific discoveries and those
we've learned that consistently
throughout time they're changing they
realize scientists are always updating
their information
so
uh with the bible we know that there's
no changing there's no there's no
variation and so i've come to find
the bible has been consistently
confirmed both scientifically
historically archaeology through
archaeology and through a number of
different ways so so
you know just remember that many people
have different agendas whether it be
intellectual agendas political agendas
in regards to their scientific
interpretation but when we go to
scripture there's always a solid
foundation into how
god wants to portray creation and
understand it you know eric we have a
book and you can read it online by just
going to the amazing facts website or
call and order it and we'll be happy to
send it to you it's called how evolution
flunk the science test it's an
interesting read
how evolution flunked the science test
and you'll find a lot of great
information and if you can accept what
the bible says
about you know origin suddenly the world
around you makes sense so we encourage
you to call and ask for that the number
is 800-835-6747
ask for the book how evolution flunked
the science test and we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks who
do we have next next we have samuel from
wisconsin samuel welcome
peace be with you brothers in christ
amen hi samuel
calling about ii peter
chapter 3
verses 17 through 18
and i see as the things as the darkness
deepens
that the light will brighten and i have
great joy at the soon coming of the lord
absolutely and and your question you're
asking about second peter chapter 3
verse 17
chapter 3 verse 17 and 18. okay let me
go ahead and read that for those who are
listening it says you therefore beloved
since you know this beforehand
beware
lest you also fall from your own
steadfastness being led away with the
errors of the wicked but growing grace
and the knowledge of our lord and savior
jesus christ to him be glory both now
and forever amen
and your question on that samuel
is that a path pastor as as my search
for the lord
that i understand is soon coming
that i do not have the fear
of the
world but the joy of the coming of the
lord absolutely you know the bible tells
us perfect love casts out fear
and if we're longing for the coming of
christ
we need not be afraid
and when we study bible prophecy we
understand that yes there will be trials
that will come
but we also know that jesus has said he
will never leave us nor forsake us
and if jesus is with you you need not
fear he will carry you through whatever
it is
that
the future has in store for you so we
can trust in god he will see us through
the bible tells us here to growing grace
and so if we're studying if we're
growing in our relationship with jesus
our trust and faith in him will grow and
we'll be looking forward to that
glorious day when jesus comes now that
doesn't mean that
you know we're we're just focused on
ourselves saying oh you want jesus to
come so that we can
we can be delivered from this world of
sin and sorrow
but we're also doing everything we can
to tell others about jesus soon coming
because we want others to be ready for
christ to come as well
so we're we're being a positive witness
in our life and our experience with
sharing with others as opportunity
arises
we're trying to do the best we can to
build up the kingdom of heaven
amen and maranatha jesus all right thank
you absolutely samuel god bless you
thanks for your call
who do we have next eric from kansas i
think eric you're on the you're you're
live on bao
good evening uh pastor jean ross and
carlos
i had a quick question i've heard
mentioned in a few messages uh
name
but i wanted to
ask is it mentioned anywhere in the
bible
a
name uh the woman that was placed at
christ's feet that was
uh found in adultery
you know in the story that we find in
scripture her name is not mentioned
specifically in that passage
but with a little
sanctified detective work we can kind of
figure out who that is
and there's a number of clues that we
find in the bible there is a woman
that's referred to as mary of magdala
and then there's a mary the sister of
martha
and she's also the sister of lazarus
now mary martha and lazarus lived in a
town of bethesda which was close to
jerusalem actually just outside
and whenever jesus was in the facility
of jerusalem he would often stay in
their home it's the same lazarus that
died that jesus raised from the dead
but then when it talks about this mary
of magdala
we also know that
mary the one from
lazarus's sister
apparently she had a bad reputation in
town because on one occasion when jesus
was there in bethlehem
there at the home of miriam arthur
mary came in and anointed the feet of
jesus and simon the pharisee said if he
was a prophet he would know what kind of
woman this is
so mary the sister of of martha and
lazarus she had a bad reputation
it's quite possible that mary left
uh bethe bethedale or where she was and
went up to magdala which is close to the
sea of galilee
and she was a prostitute uh there were a
lot of roman soldiers that were
stationed in magdala and that's where
the name mary of magdala comes from she
met jesus jesus cast out seven demons
it's quite possible that she slipped
back because you know seven times she
seemed to fall back into the same sin
it's very possible that she was also the
one that was caught committing adultery
and jesus forgave her and that's why she
was so grateful uh just a few days
before the death of jesus when she
anointed the feet of jesus she wept
and jesus said you see this woman
she loves much because she has been
forgiven much and we also know that that
was the same mary that jesus appeared to
first when he rose from the dead on the
death on on sunday morning so just a
beautiful story um you know we have a
book an amazing fact facts it's called
at jesus feet and it's the story of mary
mary magdalene or mary the the sister of
of lazarus and it gets into all of the
verses and more of the detail of who
that mary is and i think you'd really
enjoy reading it eric but i think you're
on the right track
mary there was
the sister of lazarus mary magdalene
also the woman caught in adultery is
probably the same person
all right thanks your call who do we
have next next we have robert from
washington you're on the air robert
robert welcome to the program
thank you glad you could squeeze me in
yeah absolutely
i was interested in first corinthians
verse 22.
i've heard some people say
that
because of the wording that
uh
as an adam all died but then
as it uh with christ all will be i will
meet up all will be made alive and so
does the all mean all
okay good question yeah first of all you
know in adam we all die so what does
that mean well because of adam's sin
we're all born with a sinful nature as a
result of that sinful nature we do
sinful acts and the wages of sin is
death
so because we're in adam's image because
god you know said to adam you shall
procreate in your own image according to
your likeness so in adam because of
adam's sin we're all destined to death
but because of christ the second adam
and because of his sacrifice
all can be saved but there there is a
change there there is something we need
to do
it doesn't mean we all are going to be
saved but all can be saved in other
words christ's sacrifice is of
sufficient
value to save everyone that's what the
bible tells us god can save to the
uttermost in hebrews those who come to
god through him
but we still need to come
you know the famous verse john 3 16 for
god so loved the world that he gave his
only begotten son that whosoever
believes in him shall have everlasting
life that whosoever believes that would
include anyone because christ's
sacrifice is available to anyone but we
do need to respond to that sacrifice we
need to believe we need to come to him
we need to ask forgiveness so in that
sense that's what paul is referring to
when he says so even in christ all shall
be made alive anyone that is saved is
saved because of christ we are saved in
christ but we need to we do need to come
to him because god can't save us if we
refuse to be saved if we don't repent
there is really nothing that god can do
for us well friends we want to thank you
for all of your calls and if we didn't
get to your call tonight give us another
chance give us a call next week when we
do bible answers live now don't go
anywhere just yet because we're going to
be taking some of the email questions
that have come in to bible answers live
but we do want to say goodbye to those
who are listening on satellite radio
join us next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
[Music]
hello friends welcome back to bible
answers live we've got about two minutes
before we actually end our program to
take more bible questions and want to
thank you for sending in your bible
questions if you want to email a bible
question to us the address is simply bal
questions at amazingfacts.org
that's bal questions at amazingfacts.org
pastor carlos what is our questions for
this evening number one michelle will
like an explanation of the abomination
of desolation okay the abomination of
desolation that's referring to jesus in
matthew 24 when he says when you see the
abomination of desolation spoken of by
daniel the prophet stand in the holy
place let him that being judea flee to
the mountains well in the first sense
there's sort of a dual application to
the abomination of desolation the first
is a reference to rome the roman armies
that came and surrounded jerusalem in 70
a.d actually just before 70 a.d that
resulted in the city's destruction the
christians that heard jesus speak these
words when that time came they
remembered what christ said and when
they saw the romans surrounding
jerusalem there was a moment where the
army the romans withdrew which allowed
the christians to escape from jerusalem
and when the om the roman armies came
back they did destroy the city and there
was a great slaughter
but in bible prophecy there is a
symbolic power also known as the
abomination of desolation which is also
wrong but not pagan rome in this case it
is papal rome
that is going to play a very important
role as we near the end of time
and when we see papal
rome or the papacy taking positions in
governments or influencing legislation
then we need to be aware that well the
end is near and so there's a whole study
on that but that's a dual application
for what the abomination of desolation
is
gary is asking if the enmity between
satan and the church in genesis 3 15 is
to help us hate sin
yes
that is something we need to pray for if
we want to truly overcome sin we need to
ask god to put in our hearts a hatred
for sin
you know i know many who
tell me that the things they once loved
to do after they came to know christ
they don't love to do any more and the
things that they didn't love suddenly
they begin to love so it's an evidence
that the spirit is working that there is
a change occurring in the heart that is
something that only god can do and we
need to ask for that we need to be
willing to allow god to do that work
within us yep and last jeff would like
to know uh how he can study the bible if
he hasn't studied greek and aramaic and
hebrew okay we have just a few seconds
take a look at some resources that's
free online for example strong's
concordance if you want to look at what
the meaning of the original words is uh
just strong's concordance you can look
up the verse it'll tell you what the
original meaning of the words is and
it'll help you study until next bible
answers live honest and accurate answers
to your bible questions